I could have sworn I read the last king
in the North was tauren Stark who bent
the knee to my ancestor Aegon Targaryen
hey everybody is Charlie this is going
to be my Game of Thrones Season 8 fire
and blood book Easter eggs there's a
whole bunch of references to stuff
that's happening in present day if you
haven't read it yet is a big history
book that they just published there's a
giveaway going on for that right now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video starting with number 10 Aegon
Targaryen the conquer conquered the
Seven Kingdoms not out of a desire for
power but to organize the realm rally
the realm was the theme of season seven
when Jon Snow was riding around rallying
the realm George RR Martin's suggests in
recent interviews that Aegon the
conquerer foresaw the current conflict
with the White Walkers and knew that the
only solution was to unite the Seven
Kingdoms so was just another way to tie
him to Jon Snow in present-day also
Rhaegar Targaryen named Jon Snow Aegon
after Aegon the conquerer it's no
coincidence Rhaegar was obsessed with
prophecy so he saw Jon Snow as the
culmination of a Song of Ice and Fire
the prince who was promised and wanted
to evoke that grand destiny by naming
him after the most famous Targaryen in
history 9 this is a fun one
the rise of maegor the cruel in the rise
of Cersei Lannister
so make or the cruel was Aegon the
conquerors younger son his older son
succeeded him on the throne he was a
weak King the realm descended into chaos
they were heading into a war of the five
kings situation with petty Lords trying
to take advantage of all the
indecisiveness on the throne there was a
faith militant uprising and at the time
maegor was kind of the Stannis Baratheon
of the family so he took advantage of
his brother's death to seize the throne
jumpy the line of succession over his
brothers heirs who had a stronger claim
on the throne and ruled with an iron
fist he was not a popular King so he put
down the faith militant uprising the
same way that Cersei put down her faith
militant uprising he blew up the great
Sept of the day and on its site where it
stood he built the dragon pit number
eight maegor the cruel and death by Iron
Throne this is one of my favorite Dez in
the book so he was a king henry the
eighth type person when it came to his
wives he wanted an heir badly none of
them that he married under really crazy
circumstances could give him a son
some of them he tortured and killed with
his ancestral Valyrian blade black buyer
some of them were killed by one of the
other wives so they all met very
terrible ends when the Lords of the
realm finally started to rebel in turn
against maegor Robert's rebellion style
in favor of his nephew Joe Harris who
was the rightful heir to the throne
makers Kingsguard left him alone briefly
in the throne room sitting on the Iron
Throne by himself all was well they
returned a little while later to find
him impaled on the Iron Throne under
mysterious circumstances as if the
throne itself killed him now it's
probably an assassin that took him down
hired by one of the Opposition or a
faceless person but it actually became a
rumor that the iron throne itself killed
him rejected him so to speak there's a
long-standing myth that the iron throne
will actually hurt people that aren't
meant to sit on it like people get cut
just because they sit on it weird and
there are sharp blades all over the
place of course you're gonna get cut a
little bit but getting to the Cersei of
it all
meg or in Cersei are two people that
sacrifice their families killing some of
their family members themselves to
obtain the Iron Throne
Cersei sacrificing her children like
Tommen so would it not be poetic for
Cersei to die while sitting on the Iron
Throne making it seem like the throne
itself killed her the thing that she
sacrificed so much to obtain really what
I'm hoping for is that Aria kills her
while she's sitting on the Iron Throne
so you can get the trifecta
hopefully she'll be wearing Jaime's face
but that's a bit of a long shot if they
really want to reach for the valonqar
they've made no promise that they will
do valonqar on the TV show but I do
believe that Arya will cross Circe's
name off her list 7 this is actually a
pretty cool one the true origin of
Daenerys is dragon eggs is closer to
home than you think so Joe Harris
succeeded make order the cruel to the
throne he became Jo Harris the first he
was a great king everybody loved him one
of his aunt rayna's female companions
ELISA Foreman had been living on
Dragonstone for a long time and gotten
sick of it she wanted to escape she
stole three dragon eggs and used them to
finance her escape to the east she sold
them to the Sealord of Braavos at the
time when King Joe Harris found out he
wasn't that concern he says some spice
monger in Pentos will find himself
possessed of three very costly stones
why's the birth of three young dragons
is not a thing that can be easily kept
secret whoever has them will want to
crow so here's the really cool Easter
Egg that ties that all together
Illyrio is a spice monger from Pentos
who came into possession of Daenerys as
three dragon eggs he claims that he got
them from the port of a Shia in the
shadow lands where Melisandre comes from
but it's pretty clear that Martin is
implying that Daenerys has dragon eggs
came from Dragonstone now because there
were a lot of dragons alive at that time
it's not clear which dragon exactly laid
those three specific eggs she just said
that she stole three eggs there was
Verma Thor Silverwing dream fire and
balerion the black dread Verma Thor and
dream fire did become a mated pair later
in life so you could say the dream fire
maybe lay those eggs but the books don't
take it that far six this is actually
kind of a funny one Martin named a bunch
of Tully's after Sesame Street
characters so this is how his passage
goes then is now the river Lords were a
fractious quarrelsome a lot
Kermit Tully Lord of Riverrun was their
liege lord and nominally commander of
their hosts but it must be remembered
that his lordship was but 19 years of
age and green as summer grass green like
Kermit haha see what he did there
his brother Oscar as in Oscar the Grouch
who had slain three men during the muddy
mess had been knighted on the
battlefield afterward was still greener
and cursed with a sort of prickly pride
so common in second son's
so Kermit the Frog Tully his younger
brother was Oscar the Grouch what do
these come from the reign of Jairus the
first so five later in their range a
Harris's wife Queen Alison tried to fly
her dragons north of the wall the magic
there prevented the dragons from
crossing the barrier she just gone to
inspect the Nights Watch and see what
was going on north of the wall so she
didn't have anything special in mind she
wasn't trying to look for White Walkers
or anything like that
but every time she tried to fly her
dragons north of the wall they would
veer away because Martin is implying
that the magic that protects them from
the White Walkers and keeps them from
crossing south also works in Reverse
keeping the dragons fire made flesh from
crossing in the opposite direction also
tangentially implying that season seven
episode six when Daenerys flies her
dragons north of the wall they're never
gonna do that in the books just because
the magic would prevent that from being
possible
the only way
for that to happen would be for the
White Walkers to finally bring the wall
down which they eventually will in the
books albeit as Martin is implying with
something else like the Horn of winter
instead of trying to use a dragon before
everybody's heard the theory the Tyrion
is secretly a Targaryen son of the Mad
King who may have taken advantage of
Joanna Lannister who he was known to
secretly covet so Jay Harris the first
and his wife Queen Allison's oldest
daughter Alisa Targaryen was born with
features almost exactly like Tyrians and
similar personality traits she and
Tyrion were both born with mismatched
eyes her ears were too big for her head
her smile was lopsided in when she was
really young her nose was broken very
badly and healed crooked just a
reference to Tyrion losing part of his
nose
she also had a very healthy sexual
appetite just like Tyrion so it's not
Martin saying that yes Tyrion is a
Targaryen but it is him kind of winking
at that I don't necessarily believe that
theory just because it throws a lot of
the character development between him
and Tywin under the bus it makes their
relationship a lot more poignant if he's
truly his son like you're my son and I
reject you as opposed to him hating
Tyrion because he really is someone
else's son but 3 there's a tower of joy
reference so Aemon Targaryen who was
alive during the dance of the dragons
ran off with his own version of Lyanna
stark - their version of the Tower of
joy in a really twisted version of
events you see where this is going the
tower that they ran away to was
Harrenhal which is cursed so the minute
you know that somebody's running away to
Harrenhal you know they're gonna meet a
really bad end his secret bride
eventually gave birth to a son just like
Rhaegar and Lyanna did but the other big
twist was is that when the baby was born
the woman demanded that everyone bow
down to the babe as if he was the prince
who was promised this grand destiny in
front of him so she kind of went mad and
later they referred to her as the witch
queen of Harrenhal - we just talked
about the alternate version of events
where the White Walkers make it south of
the wall fire and blood does reference
Valyrian horns like the Horn of winter
and Dragon bind her to get a name drop
when King Joe Harris is thinking about
one of his sons who's just been killed
the passage reads the old king never
dreamed that a man's death in 92 AC
would be like the hell horns of Valyrian
Legend bringing death and destruction
down on all those who heard their
so remember Euron has dragon binder in
the books but the Horn of winter is
probably going to be what brings down
the wall in winds of winter but we'll
have to wait a while to find out about
that it won on his big book tour george
RR martin revealed more details about
the prequel series he said that it's
actually going to take place 5,000 years
before events in present day squashing
the timeline quite a bit and he went on
to say that at that time Valyrians are
just now discovering dragons roosting in
the fourteen flames peninsula making it
sound like they're taking their time a
little bit more with dragons on the
prequel series than they did on the main
series you saw Daenerys hatch her
dragons at the end of season one but if
Valerians are just now discovering
dragons in the 14 flames as of the
beginning of the prequel series maybe
we'll get some teaser for that at the
end of season one but it sounds like
it's just them hedging their bets trying
to tell you that there won't be dragons
littering the sky everywhere but we'll
also probably get to witness part of the
rise of the Valyrian freehold while
we're seeing all the other stuff
happening in Westeros during this period
let me know what your favorite Easter
Egg from the book is if I didn't mention
it in the video there are hundreds and
hundreds of references so this is barely
scratches the surface congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last big
video Brian Dempsey please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for that new
Game of Thrones season 8 trailer and
click here for my season 8 episode 1
preview thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight